the adventure is on for the kardashian
kids northwest and penelope district go
ziplining in the woods and enjoy some
quality time with kourtney kardashian
and travis barker in the great outdoors
[Music]
check out penelope disick fearlessly
jumping off the platform and court is
one proud mom writing i'll always be her
cheerleader as she loudly cheers on her
10 year old daughter
and she gets a kick out of her 7 year
old son rain getting tied up on the
zipline
[Applause]
but just wait until you see quartz hubby
travis barker face his fears
blink 182 drummer admits he's always
been afraid of heights but judging by
how effortlessly he pushed himself down
the slope travis looks like a pro we're
just you know living our best lives
yeah
of course court's niece kim's daughter
north is no stranger to a wilderness
adventure
back in june she celebrated her 9th
birthday with a spooky themed camping
party it's really lit and fun and crazy
cam dished on all the deets during a
tonight show appearance telling jimmy
fallon northey is shaping up to be quite
the beauty guru we took about eight kids
eight girls and we went camping in the
wilderness and she wanted it to be
really spooky and she wanted
like these
mannequin heads and she taught everyone
there was a whole class that she taught
her friends how to do
special effects wounds and
scars here's to hoping we see moments
like that on season two of the
kardashians no matter how crazy things
are
we're always gonna be family one thing's
for sure fans can always expect the
unexpected with the reality tv family
who keeps us on our toes
i don't know what's happening with you i
can't tell my kids i'm scared they have
enough problems they don't need to worry
about mom while we wait to uncover what
exactly is going on with momager kris
jenner she told et ahead of season one
their new series is more focused on raw
family moments i love that
the episodes are more a little bit
documentary style and i think that you
have a real insight into what the girls
are doing not only you know what you see
in the press or whatever but what's
really happening behind the scenes
[Music]
you